we never thought we'd say this but we
miss you Maleficent we haven't seen your
wicked face or heard your maniacal laugh
since the very first descendants film we
know mal had her reasons for turning you
into a lizard but why didn't she turn
you back once she freed everyone from
the Isle of the laws that just doesn't
seem fair if we were you we'd be
planning our revenge it's just too bad
that you're still a lizard we really
missed you in descendants three and
everyone in auradon lived happily ever
after except for Maleficent what
happened to the strongest Disney villain
of all time
what rock is she hiding under and is she
still a wizard keep watching to find out
your mother did she shrank to the size
of the love in her heart
growing up with Maleficent as a mom was
super tough but it did turn mal into the
fighter she is today
sure Maleficent wanted to bring down the
barrier and punish everyone who'd
wronged her but she did have her reasons
Philippa didn't put all her eggs into
one basket when she sent mal de Oregon
with a special task but she never
expected her daughter to have a change
of heart
Maleficent tried to take on mal and her
friends at the end of the first
descendants film but Mouse magic was
infused with love
whereas Maleficent stem from anger so
when their spells clashed Maleficent was
transformed into a puny lizard well if
it since miserable existence is living
proof that sometimes you get exactly
what you asked for I will be able to
bend both food Oh Maleficent won it was
for Mao to bring down the barrier using
fairy godmothers wand and that's exactly
what happened the next
you ask for something be sure to be
specific fairy godmother willingly gave
mal her wand at the end of descendant 3
and now took down the barrier for good
and while mal got to welcome her dad to
auradon with open arms
this same can't be said about her mother
so why would mal side with Hades instead
of her dear old mom
Hades made it crystal clear that
Maleficent isn't the easiest person to
get along with but when Hades accused
mal of hating her mother she quickly
fired back we know that mal kept
Maleficent as a pet throughout
descendants - but we haven't seen the
little evil lizard since then if turning
Maleficent into a lizard and keeping her
that way is the symbol of Mao's love
we'd hate to see what she does to
someone she hates in descendants - mal
decides to move back to the Isle of the
Lost where she belongs
we see her put Maleficent into a tiny
little box and bring her back to the
Isle but since magic doesn't work on the
Isle shouldn't Maleficent have turned
back into her usual self like melded
into Sundance three well apparently not
Maleficent might be evil but living the
rest of her days as a lizard is
something we wouldn't wish on our worst
enemy now should have turned her mother
back and locked her back up on the Isle
with the rest of the villains but this
never happened
so why didn't mal turn her mom back into
her usual self
well for one mal is probably terrified
of what her mother will say once she
finds her voice again who wouldn't be
furious with her child for keeping them
as a pet Maleficent wouldn't hesitate to
get revenge on mal and since mal
probably feels guilty she might not be
able to beat her mother once again but
the most obvious reason why Maleficent
is still a lizard has everything to do
with how evil she is taking down the
barrier and freeing everyone from the
Isle just wouldn't have been possible if
Maleficent was still calling the shots
she's more interested in revenge than
making amends
if Maleficent was still ruling the isle
the people of auradon would have never
agreed to take down the barrier because
that would give Maleficent all of her
powers back and she just loves throwing
evil spells around whether mal would
free her
or not is sort of irrelevant after all
we haven't seen the tiny lizard since
Mao brought it to the Isle indeed - so
what if now actually lost her mom on the
Isle making it impossible to undo this
spell Mao had to leave in a hurry once
King been with kidnapped by uma and her
pirates so it's possible that she left
her belongings behind and couldn't
retrieve her dear old mum we just hope
that Maleficent made it out of the box
she was being held captive in without
the proper food and nourishment that
little lizard would be able to survive
Maleficent might be evil and super
powerful but she does have a heart would
Hades have married her if she didn't
well if ascent is complicated and
unpredictable but she deserves some
credit and she definitely doesn't
deserve to live the rest of her days as
a lizard although Hades saved Audrey at
the end of descendant 3 therefore
redeeming himself in the eyes of mal
Maleficent could have done the exact
same thing if Maleficent had used her
sceptre to heal Audrey she would have
patched things up with Queen Leah
Sleeping Beauty and Audrey all at once
there is nothing that says I'm sorry
like saving the granddaughter or your
enemy unfortunately Maleficent never got
the chance to redeem herself she's
nowhere to be found
do you think Maleficent deserves to live
the rest of her life as a lizard or do
you think mal should undo the spell tell
us in the comment section everyone in
auradon knows that Hades is mouseka
which got us thinking who's your dad uma
you've been pretty much tight-lipped
about your family tree sure you're the
daughter of Ursula but your abilities
surpass your mother's by a long shot
you're smart resourceful and curious so
you love to found out who your dad is at
some point or another so come on uma
tell us the truth
I'm done waiting for a day that will
never come there's way more to Malan
umas relationship than meets the eye
they're stronger together for some
undisclosed reason and we believe we
know why watch until the end to find out
what mal Ouma and Maui have in common
there are two ways Malin Ouma could be
related and they both have to do with
Hades Disney often draws inspiration
from Greek mythology which is where the
Lord of the underworld originates from
when it comes to Greek mythology Malin
Huma aren't related but when you combine
the Disney verse with the mythological
world
uma and Maus family tree does in fact
cross branches in the earliest The
Little Mermaid drafts King Triton and
Ursula were brother and sister
and since Hades is train's uncle this
means that he's Ursula's uncle too
this would make human mouth distant
cousins it would also make uma and Ariel
first cousins - although Disney chose
omit Ursula and Triton's relationship
from the movie there are still some
subtle hints that link them together but
for now let's put the Disney verse in
Greek mythology aside and focus on the
descendants world things are very
different in the United States of
auradon and so is the relationship
between Malin uma in this universe
they're much closer than distant cousins
they're half sisters let's look at some
of the facts Malin umer are about the
same age and grew up together on the
Isle of the Lost
who must father has to have lived on the
Isle or her conception wouldn't make
sense
Hades told Malin descendants 3 that
being married to her mother wasn't easy
so we know that Hades and Maleficent got
divorced right around the time that mal
was born so it's possible that Hades
dated around after calling it quits with
Maleficent there are so many clues that
point towards mal and uma being half
siblings one
I'm being Mallen Houmas instant
connection since childhood but something
happened for Mao to suddenly turn on
Emma in the novel rise of the Isle of
the Lost and we're thinking Maleficent
had a hand in this
Maleficent must have known about Hades
and Ursula's fling which would make her
despise uma so separating uma and mal
would have been a top priority and since
mal was keen on making her mother proud
she probably didn't think twice before
betraying uma being able to transform
into fantastical beasts is another thing
these two BK's have in common
luma can turn into a sack a Lia she can
control water and you see magic and Mao
can turn into a fire-breathing dragon
both uma and mal can use complicated
spells and luma can even use spells
right out of mouths Belva that doesn't
sound like sea magic to us Malin Umar
are the only BK's in auradon who can
transform into large creatures in the
blink of an eye sure they might get this
from their mother's side of the family
but if mal and Numa were only half
magical why would they be stronger than
their mothers it sounds like they have
some other powers at play here which
likely come from their shared father
Hades we also noticed that Malin Ouma
have similar hair colors although
Maleficent doesn't show her hair she's
known for repping the color purple so we
can only assume that she has a head of
purple hair like mouths Katie's hair is
vibrant blue put those together and you
get mouths purple blue hair centers Ouma
her mother Ursula was voiced by Whoopi
Goldberg in descendants 2
[Music]
so we can only imagine that Ursula has
dark skin and white hair but Houmas hair
is a mix of white black and blue so
where does this mysterious blue color
come from we're pointing a finger at
Hades but the most obvious sign that
Huma and mal are sisters has to do with
Hades amber before giving mal his number
Hades told her that it only responded
fully to him because he's a god only
half the amber won't do everything for
you that it does but for some odd reason
uma and mal were able to use the Amber
to its full potential when together now
didn't accomplish this with edj or
Carlos but when it came to Emma magic
happened on top of that
uma seashell necklace was also reacting
to mal so maybe a sense their closer
relationship Malin uma quickly realized
that they were strong together but they
never explained why and guys we doubted
us to do with the power of love or
friendship because if that were the case
mal wouldn't have needed whom had to
save auradon Hades told mal that if she
got the Ember wet it would be game over
yet somehow she managed to revive it
with umas help now couldn't ignite the
Ember alone she could only use it at
half capacity but if malli numr are
truly Hades daughters that makes them
both demigods and the power of two
demigod should equal out to the power of
one this explains why malli Numa were
able to do what they did
and luckily Audrey in the scepter were
no match for Emma and mouth powers
combined do you guys think that Malin
Umar half sisters cousins were simply
unrelated tell us in the comments
section dear Jay and Gill we hope you
guys are having a blast on your vacation
you're probably surfing down the Amazon
River you know
in a jungle River find a lost
civilization oh maybe a penguin swinging
from branch to branch in total Tarzan
fashion and eating buzzy rocks aka
coconuts you guys really do seem like
the best of pals the J we need to know
what happened between you and Lonnie you
guys grew super close by the end of
descendants two but now you've committed
to a year-long vacation and Lonnie is
nowhere to be found we want some answers
J we're in auradon could Lonnie have
gone we can't believe she wasn't in
descendants three
but according to Diane Doan the actress
who plays her Lonnie had her reasons for
keeping away keep watching to get all
the deets we definitely weren't the only
ones who noticed that Lonnie was a
no-show in descendant 3 this strikes us
as strange especially since Lonnie was
such a vital character in both
descendants 1 & 2 Lonnie is brave smart
and unpredictable which would have made
her a total asset plus she knows how to
wield a sword like there's no tomorrow
so she would have been a valued ally
during the fight with the metal nights
while Lonnie has her reasons for keeping
away it makes no sense that she would
miss her best friend Jane's birthday
party and since she's such a good
fighter the Lonnie we all know and love
totally would have offered her services
once she found out about the sleep spell
but most peculiar of all is how Jade
didn't even mention Lonnie once
throughout the film we got the
impression that Jay and Lonnie were
couple goals at the end of descendants -
Jay supported her and helped her become
the captain of the swords and shields
team whereas Lonnie saw Jay for who he
truly was and risked your life to help
the VK save Ben this be kak relationship
was a dream come true which is why tons
of fans have shipped Johnny since the
very beginning we were certain that
these two would be dating by the time
descendants 3 rolled around but no
Lonnie was nowhere to be found and Jay
didn't feel the need to mention her at
all it's possible that Jay and Lonnie
gave romance a try but quickly realized
that they were better off as friends
this would explain why Lonnie wasn't
present and why Jay chose to keep quiet
about the whole ordeal another thing
worth mentioning is that descendants
three
takes place in the summertime the vks
revealed that audrey was staying at
auradon prep for the summer because of
summer school
theory hook thought this was hilarious
and blamed summer school for Audrey's
villainous rampage but we all know that
that's not the case if lani wasn't at
auradon prep that means she didn't want
to take summer classes and probably
remained in her hometown of Northern Wei
but according to Diane Lani had no
choice but to be written out of the
script and will reveal why in just a few
moments the real reason why Lani wasn't
in descendents three is stated on her
descendents fandom page here we find out
that Lani is absent due to touring the
united states of auradon with her roar
team knowing this it makes perfect sense
that Lani wasn't at Jane's birthday
party or involved in descendants 3
whatsoever but part of us still wishes
that Jay would have talked about Lani at
some point in the film we were really
rooting for this couple another reason
why Lani wasn't in d3 has everything to
do with the storyline name characters
like Jay Carlos and Doug didn't have the
most lines throughout the film so adding
Lani to the equation would have
complicated things in the end the script
for d3 was designed to follow maui be
Emma and Audrey's stories which sort of
put other characters on the back burner
so at first we thought that Lonnie was
purposely written out of the d3 script
and complicate things but that's not
exactly true in the end the real reason
Lani wasn't in descendents 3 has
everything to do with the actress who
portrays her Diane is a 28 year old
actress who started acting back in 2009
she played in a handful of short movies
before being cast as Lani in 2014 for
the next three years Diane would voice
her character and Disney descendants
school of secrets and descendant wicked
world and she would also appear in d1
and d2 but by the time Diane wrapped up
filming for descendants 2 she realized
that she wanted to expand her horizons
so she started auditioning for different
roles so when it came time to film
descendants 3 Diana has some conflict
issues that she could not ignore as a
result the actress was unable to reprise
her role as Lani
which led her to being written out of
the script what we do love the J and
Lonnie ship we couldn't help but fall in
love with J and gills budding friendship
throughout the three quill always are
you get a kick out of a berry this I
like the way that you can bounce around
and jump up things Jane Doe might not
have bonded if Lonnie had been around so
in the end we're pretty happy with how
things worked out if Lonnie had been
present in the film the writers might
have made J and Lonnie an item which
could have prevented J from going on a
year-long voyage with Gill you know what
will be fun to go rafting in a jungle
river find a lost civilization or maybe
a penguin let's put it to a vote to find
out who the most popular couple is
comment jay and Lonnie or J and Gil in
the comments section below
I was just going to see you because I'm
gonna be queen
we love you Hades you were by far one of
our favorite new characters in
descendants three we loved your duet
with mal and we still can't get over
your cool blue hair and badass outfit
we're so happy that you and now we're
able to patch things up so now that
you're a freak on will you be taking
your daughter to the underworld for a
family vacation
we've seriously loved to see that we all
thought that mal had no clue who her
father was but we now know that's far
from the truth Malon Hades relationship
has a few loose ends we want to tie up
watch until the end to find out the
truth about Hades and mouths
relationship who is mouths father that's
the question that's been on everyone's
mind ever since the first descendants
film aired in 2015 it was thought that
mal had no idea who her dad was but that
turned out to be a lie in the
under-the-sea trailer and mouse stumbled
across a blue orb in a forest and
believes it to be her dad so it's safe
to assume that mal has known who her dad
was for many years now in descendants
3-mile in Hades seeing an amazing duet
that gives us an inside scoop on their
relationship Eadie's is convinced that
he did malice solid by taking himself
out of the picture he says her daddy
issues have made her stronger and that
she was better off without him
one line that proves just how much he
cares about his daughter
he tells mal to pay him some respect
because it's not easy to neglect so this
means that abandoning mouth wasn't an
easy thing for him to do but that wasn't
enough to convince mal who still
couldn't forgive him from walking out on
her to find out who her real father was
Mao must have used the process of
elimination
and since Maleficent is one of the most
powerful villains of all time it makes
sense that she would fall for someone
equally as powerful as her if not more
at some point or another mouth figured
it out and she thought that Hades didn't
care about her but something changes
after the do what you gotta do duet
celia tells mal something that changes
the way she sees her dad forever after
finding out that Edie's is mouths dad
Celia says so I guess that's the reason
why he's always asking about you hearing
this helps mal forgive Hades after all
he was secretly checking up on her from
afar it's also possible that mal asked
around the aisle and found out that her
mother and Hades used to be a thing it
isn't the first time Maleficent in Hades
have been coupled together in the Disney
verse back in 2003 Hades and Maleficent
were shown going on a date during a
house of mouse episode titled Halloween
with Hades so there was a paper trail
for mal de follow although it might look
like Hades wants nothing to do with
anybody in descendants 3 it's actually
hinted that Hades owns a souvlaki
restaurant in descendants 2 there's a
sign that says Hades of Lackey it's
under this world hung up right next to
the curl up and die salon so Hades and
mal might have crossed paths many times
over the years and who knows maybe he
gave mal a free gyro or two which could
have tipped her off quite a show you put
on the other day right back atcha a
tease wasn't there for mal when she was
growing up but he's here for her now
sure he did abandon her as a baby and
attack her with his Ember for some
unknown reason but he's still a million
times better than Melissa
when it comes to Maleficent and Hades
Hades is clearly the better parent yes
he may be a little wicked but he's
nowhere near as criminally insane as
Maleficent Maleficent didn't care about
Mouse feelings at all
so we're team Hades from here on out in
Mallen Hades duet Hades asks mal if
she'll take him to auradon for some
father-daughter bonding time but she's
just not interested
all mal once is the Ember eighties hate
auradon and everything it stands for but
he wants to make things right with his
daughter so he gives her his most prized
possession if that's not saying sorry
you don't know what is
when mal walked out of his den Hades
whispered that's my girl which shows us
just how proud of her he is Mau always
wanted to make her mother proud but
nothing she did was ever evil enough so
it's nice to know that Hades has been
proudly watching his daughter from afar
since the very beginning that Hades road
to forgiveness didn't stop there
when mal returned to the Isle and asked
her dad to save Audrey he did so without
a question
despite being past the barrier Hades
didn't try to escape the second he got
his hands on the Ember instead he saved
Audrey's life and returned to the Isle
but not before doing something totally
sweet and selfless Hades gave his ember
to mal before being taken away by the
guards this touching moment was enough
to make anyone tear up by the end of
descendants three it's clear that mal
has forgiven her dad for leaving she
hugged Hades and welcomes him to auradon
with open arms
Malon Hades are definitely going to have
an amazing relationship they'll walk her
down the aisle when she marries bed
and they'll take her on a family trip to
the underworld whenever she's willing we
loved this song do what you gotta do
which song from d3 was your favorite
tell us in the comments section and
that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time on the things
[Music]
[Music]